When was the last time you were the first person to do something?
"The LPL has never won before, but that will change today!"
"Evo world champion, Arslan Ash!"
"Cloud9 are your ELEAGUE Major champions!"
For most people pioneering anything is a pipe dream at best, but meet Ewok
the fourteen-year-old deaf female streamer who joined FaZe Clan back in July as a content creator.
(applause)
If her rapid rise to success is a sign of things to come she's going to kicking some serious ass in the near future
"Ewok! Ewok! Ewok!"
She broke the glass ceiling on a notoriously bro-esque gaming org
and is also probably the first deaf Twitch partner.
Here is what she had to say.
Now Ewok was born deaf,
so she can't rely on in-game sounds to know where the enemy is or anything else going on in the game, for that matter.
"Do you hear that?"
"Yeah."
"What is that?"
"Maybe the missile?"
Instead, Ewok uses sound visualization,
which turns the game's audio into visual cues.
And if you think that sounds easy in a game like Fortnite where there's a ton of 3D space? Think again.
"Bro, this is so hard. It sounds like everything's under you or in front of you."
"There's no left or right audio, wow."
Ewok's popularity steadily rose after she joined Twitch in January of this year, and it's pretty easy to see why
But Ewok's biggest viewer bump came after popular streamer TimTheTatman hosted her channel.
TimTheTatman: "This girl I am about to host chat, she's deaf, okay?"
"So everyone go give her a lot of love."
Ewok's subscribers and live viewership went from hundreds to thousands pretty quickly.
And the gaming world was all ears.
FaZe Apex: "She's deaf, she's thirteen, and she's disgustingly good."
TimTheTatman: "She's deaf. Like she can't hear. And she's insane, she's so good. Better than me!"
NICKMERCS: "She actually does all this with no sound."
NICKMERCS: "If I am playing with no sound, I don't have any idea. Oh my god."
Ewok started playing with some of Twitch's biggest names like Ninja, Dr. Lupo and Liquid Chap.
Ninja: "Ewok!"
"Absolutely well played!"
And FaZe Clan really embraced Ewok even adding an I-love-you sign language emoji to their Twitter handle.
FaZe Kay: "We put this together for you....FaZe merch, there is definitely some exclusive stuff in there."
She might be young, but she's definitely not shy.
Ewok joined other unhappy players calling out the Fortnite devs on Twitter after they added the BRUTE mech to the game.
Tfue: "I'm f#@$ing dead. This game is ass."
And on top of it Ewok showing no signs of slowing down,
she often talks about the next generation chasing their dreams and just going after it.
Now, it's no secret that the internet is a shitty and toxic place sometimes. But Ewok's story stands out as a beacon of positivity
She's turned what many would see is a disadvantage into an inspiring story for others.
And that's how you do it first.
Ewok: "FaZe up!"